nowadays it feels like you can take your
pick of pretty much any gaming franchise
On Any Given platform and chances are
they've been rebuilt around some kind of
randomized reward system spend real
world money or countless hours of play
time or for the chance of getting
something cool broadly speaking most
Gamers refer to these random reward
systems as loot boxes and their Mass
adoption is one of the most
controversial things to happen to
mainstream gaming in the last 15 years
though Community backlash has led many
mainstream titles to remove loot boxes
altogether they remain a profitable
means of monetization for hundreds of
games despite consistent fears of their
mechanical similarities to gambling and
their potential to cause financial and
psychological harm to vulnerable players
so our loot boxes gambling and do they
carry the same potential for harm as
gambling does we're going to unpack loot
boxes and their impact on the industry
and speak to psychology experts to try
and understand the effect loot boxes
have on the people who open them we
thought games were fine you literally
stuck a casino in a game and now we know
that games maybe are not fine because
there's a casino in them
back in 2020 the British charity Gambler
Ware released a paper titled lifting the
lid on loot boxes a report into what
they call the convergence of gaming and
gambling it's a mammoth 54-page document
citing dozens of surveys articles and
studies to find out why players engage
with loot boxes and how they feel when
they do given that Publishers go out of
their way to convince you that loot
boxes are absolutely nothing like
gambling preparing comparisons to things
like trading cards and bizarrely
chocolate eggs the information in this
report seems pretty Stark so let's break
it down the report shows consistent
evidence of links between loot box
interaction and problem gambling
behaviors and details the way in which
developers look to traditional gambling
systems for inspiration when designing
loot boxes that's why they often look
like slot machines cards dice roulette
wheels and so on the similarities aren't
surface level either loot boxes use
variable ratio schedules of
reinforcement which is a fancy way of
saying that because rewards are dished
out at random you're incentivized to
keep opening boxes in the hope that the
next box will give you what you want
research has shown this variable ratio
schedule is the best way to keep us
hooked and if that sounds a lot like a
slot machine well that's because it's
literally exactly how a slot machine
works weirdly there's not loads of stuff
in here about developers being inspired
by chocolate eggs
it also shows that for players who
engage with loot boxes their motivations
track very closely with problem gambling
behaviors things like the excitement of
opening boxes peer pressure and the
feeling of being motivated by Temptation
and that the majority of loot box
revenue is generated from a small number
of individuals who spend a lot of money
and score highly on problem gambling
measures also known as Wales essentially
this report suggests that many loot box
systems are aesthetically and
mechanically inspired by gambling they
motivate engagement in the same way as
gambling and they carry the same
potential for harm as gambling does now
when I first read this report I assumed
this was going to be the Smoking Gun for
loot boxes and chart a clear path
towards regulation but as it turns out
it's not quite that simple this is Pete
etchels he's a professor of psychology
and science communication at bath spa
University and he's also written lost in
a good game a book about the
psychological effects good and bad of
video games we've seen a very distant
line that the more you spend on loot
boxes the more likely you are to score
highly on measures of problem gambling
whether that translates into harm or not
is a different question we don't know
whether it's that we spend more on loot
boxes that drives you to become more
problematic in terms of gambling habit
if that's the case then loot boxes are
basically a Gateway mechanism for
problem gambling or it could be that
people who have a higher propensity
towards problem gambling are more drawn
to games with loot boxes in them and
these sorts of mechanisms are targeting
vulnerable populations so either way
it's not good but there's a third option
as well which is that there's a third
variable that we haven't thought about
yet that is driving both either in
somebody's life or in the game itself or
combination of the two that makes people
spend more money on loot boxes and also
makes them more problematic gamblers and
if that's the case then loot boxes
aren't necessarily the problem in that
scenario if you've ever wondered why
loot boxes and other random reward
systems aren't better regulated despite
their obvious similarities to gambling
this lack of causation is why until
research can prove that loot boxes
directly cause problem gambling
behaviors it's essentially down to the
player to understand any potential risk
and decide for themselves whether to
play the game and engage with these
systems or not
[Music]
everybody is equipped to make that
decision many games that feature loot
boxes are rated as age-appropriate for
children and according to the Gambler
wear report 25 to 50 percent of children
in adolescents have opened a loot box
which would suggest that whatever
measures are in place to stop children
from interacting with loot boxes just
aren't working this is Alexander Chris
he's a clinical psychologist and author
of The Gaming mind and he's an advocate
for the psychological benefits of
playing games he is not a fan of loot
boxes I don't like I don't like them and
so I have avoided buying them or
participating in that myself and from a
psychological standpoint I see loot
boxes as kind of like violating some of
the basic terms of play my concern more
lies like on the game developer side
right of what is their responsibility in
sort of providing an experience that is
intended to be engaging and entertaining
and meaningful in some way versus you
know a cash grab that maybe kind of
plays on our worst Natures in a sense
many Publishers will point to the fact
that you can play these modes without
spending any money but they often
require a huge time commitment instead
sure when Star Wars Battlefront 2 came
out you could technically unlock Darth
Vader for free but it would be in
exchange for around 40 hours of play
time to generate enough credits to
unlock one character
wouldn't it be so much easier to just
buy a loot box and get the credits that
way instead it's almost like that's what
their plan was the whole time what is
our responsibility as Citizens as
parents as people who are making games
to keep in mind the most vulnerable
people who are going to be using the
game I think that in some ways part of
my concerns about all this is almost
defensive because I've spent part of my
professional career sort of trying to
defend games in a certain way as this
thing that's not as dangerous as people
think they don't reach out and grab you
and turn you into a murderer right but
if a young person yeah goes into a game
and they walk away having spent hundreds
of dollars of their parents money
without maybe understanding even what
that means then it is a social problem
right it's not just a game problem it is
like bad for games reputation if we know
that some vulnerable people are going to
come into contact with a system that can
prey on vulnerable people what is our
responsibility to think about how those
systems work how they're regulated and
so on it's worth returning to to that
statistic that between 25 and 50 percent
of children have opened the loot box
Children and adolescents are especially
vulnerable to feelings of peer pressure
the fear of missing out and wanting a
quick fix solution particularly when the
potential rewards are only available for
a limited time however research has
shown that this also applies to other
vulnerable groups such as those with
ADHD impulse control disorders and of
course those who already suffer from
problematic gambling behaviors where
video games were once considered a kind
of safe space these mechanics have the
potential to undercut that safety for
the very people who are most at risk we
look at the effects that video games can
have on us and by and large positive or
negative video games haven't got much of
an impact until you start changing the
games themselves how are those sorts of
mechanisms are implemented can change
our our opinion or our barometer or
video game effects really not being much
to worry about to potentially being
quite problematic we thought games were
fine and then you you literally stuck a
casino in a game and now we know that
games maybe are not fine because there's
a casino in them
so what's stopping loot boxes being
regulated unsurprisingly it's a
complicated issue often games will
reference random reward mechanics in
their ESRB or Peggy rating
specifications but these do not impact
the actual age rating of the game Peggy
also offers Parental Guidance which
states parents carers or other
responsible adults should check to see
what is being offered before making any
purchase on behalf of a child which
simply shifts the blame for any harm
onto the shoulders appearance besides
the warning on the packaging is
absolutely minuscule there is a reason
why you know you're not allowed into a
casino if you're under 18. if a 12 year
old has their parents credit card that
doesn't mean that they could get into a
casino and like it's the parents fault
right like if the casino lets a child in
whether they have a way to pay or not
it's on them right that's that's the
regulation That's the Law if the people
running the game could be blamed because
a 10 year old got a hold of their
parents credit card then they would
instantly create new safeguards to make
sure that the people who were engaging
in this stuff were at least
hypothetically people who had the
capacity to consent to taking these
risks or sort of participating in this
way the fact is that regulatory bodies
are simply not agile enough to keep up
with the industry some countries have
passed legislation but simple changes
such as giving away loot box gifts with
every purchase of in-game currency allow
total evasion of the legislation with
the result being little to no effect on
the financial performance of loot boxes
or the demographic interacting with them
in 2017 Belgium ruled that loot boxes
constituted unlicensed gambling and
banned them entirely but the ban has
proven almost impossible to enforce as
most loot boxes do not allow you to cash
out or exchange the rewards for anything
that's traditionally deemed of value in
many countries they cannot legally be
considered gambling at all any more than
buying a pack of Pokemon cards or I
suppose a chocolate egg now this might
will sound pretty bleak but there are
reason to be optimistic the fact that so
many governments Charities and
psychologists around the world are
researching loot boxes and their effects
is a good thing regardless of whether or
not it directly leads to change many
loot box studies are pre-registered
meaning they say in advance how they're
going to collect and analyze their data
and many of these studies make their
data openly available meaning there's an
increasingly Rich ever expanding set of
data to use in research in the future
the more we understand about loot boxes
and their effects the more likely we are
to end up with a future where the
harmful elements of loot boxes are
minimized without compromising the
opportunity for free-to-play developers
to fund their game from well-informed
consenting adults and we're closer to
that future now than ever before we're
not talking anymore about our games good
or bad for us because it's a stupid
question to ask and nobody cares are
there particular aspects of games or are
there particular mechanisms that are
implemented in games that if you take
them out or add them in do you see a net
Improvement in well-being or net
reduction that understanding will help
to inform a less psychologically
problematic way of monetizing games and
I think that's a really interesting area
of research right and as we become more
Savvy about doing research in this area
and we start to kind of engage a little
bit more with industry we'll be able to
do more useful research like that
thanks so much for watching this week's
episode of Mind Games next week we're
covering the game that fights dementia
so make sure you're subscribed and check
your feeds for that next week for more
information on the guests and the topics
covered in this video check the
description down below and I'll see you
next time